he was in the car with me and he went to
go pick him up and we both crashed into
each other but it was my fault how did
you guys crash into each other I I'll
take the blame I was under the influence
he's fine I'll she was she was going
straight and I turned the car around not
realizing she was not I dropped him off
in front of the Walgreens that's right
in front of grovelin a I dropped him off
there he was walking and he went to go
pick him up and he bumped into me but
I'm under the influence and I'll take
the blame and it's perfectly fine I'm
[Music]
Police
Department
[Music]
what's going on man what's your name sir
tus what is it Wellington Taurus is
there anybody else in the apartment with
you yes sir my little brother and my
girlfriend sir what's your girlfriend's
name lyanna grenia sir okay can we can
we talk to her please no problem sir
anybody hurt no
sir
why you come out here yes sir told your
brother hi what's going
on it's all
my who's driving which car I was driving
the El I was driving Honda the blue
Honda what happened I just went back to
go pick him up and didn't realize that
she was to the left he was in the car
with me me and he went to go pick him up
and we both crashed into each other but
it was my fault how did you guys crash
into each other I I'll take the blame I
was under the influence he's fine I'll
she was she was going straight and I
turned the car around not realizing she
was me I dropped him off in front of the
Walgreens it's right in front of gropel
a I dropped him off there he was walking
and he went to go pick him up and he
bumped into me but I'm under the
influence and I'll take the blame and
it's perfectly fine I'm fine with that
so how did you get back here now cuz we
all we all we all walk together my car
is still closer to the wall found yeah
yeah my car is still over there his car
is parked over here but he's perfectly
fine and it's all my fault well how come
you didn't call the police cuz we were
trying to figure it out through
insurance companies and all that we were
trying to avoid all you left like debris
all over the roadway and your vehicle's
disabled in the road up there I
understand it's all my
fault all right oh who's in the car
highspeed chases we got a unruly
suspects I will kill that mother T me no
do it stay in the bo I like dramatic DUI
I'm a pass TR to do and shocking body
cam footage hey get on the ground get on
the ground law on crime presents body
cam the place for real raw and wild
police videos you should have seen it it
was good it's on body camera I'll show
it to you catch the action and subscribe
to our new YouTube channel
now I was in the car driving I was you
in the blue car down there I was in the
blue car driving he was in the silver
car he's fine who's the car or
too do you
on
where's your other shoe at I just took
it off in the bathroom but I could yeah
why don't we get your shoe on you want
to want me to put it on yeah please
[Music]
yeah isn't
here
it's not in there somewhere in here but
I'll put these ODS
on how old are you 19 22 you're 22 yeah
oh my ID my ID is in the blue color
[Music]
yeah all
right where where were you guys tonight
Groveland I was coming from Groveland as
but we were coming from from Atlantic
City okay who was coming from Atlantic
City me and your boyfriend but he wasn't
he was just coming from lywood what were
you doing over in lywood I was that's
where he lived
okay okay so you were coming from
Atlantic City with your boyfriend in the
car right driving the blue driving I was
the one driving I know you keep saying
that like it's like it like it's I'm
just letting you know that I was the one
driving
okay
um
you get what did you get in a fight with
your boyfriend is that why you left him
at no no no I was just dropping him off
at my car which was where I dropped him
off right in front of the Walgreens okay
where his brother was going to pick him
up why was his brother going to pick him
up to take him to lywood yeah cuz he
wanted to go home I live in you live you
live here by yourself he lives in lwood
with brother okay and you said you've
been drinkinking
tonight okay how much have you had to
drink tonight AI what's a few I've had
like two beers and two shots two beers
and two shots at what time like over an
hour ago okay well without looking at a
clock what time do you think it is right
now like 2 a.m. I would say right now if
I had to gu at 2 a.m. okay and what time
did you start
drinking I'd say around midnight okay
all right all right so what we're going
to do is um we're going to go outside
and run you through some balance tests
to make sure you're okay okay and then
we'll go from there so why why don't we
head out this way tell the boyfriend to
come inside
okay do no
I all right so what what what level of
Education have you completed in your
lifetime I've had two years of college
and nothing after that okay so you know
your alphabet from A to Z without seeing
it without skipping any letters
absolutely all right so why don't you go
ahead and and and do your alphabet from
A to Z don't sing it don't skip any
letters straight straight through a b c
d e f g h i j k l m n o p q r s t v w h
y and z okay all right do you have any
injuries from this accident are you hurt
at all I'm fine okay did the airbag go
off no okay all right so why don't you
see this line here yes why don't you
come up to that line notice stand right
here right here facing me come over here
back up a little bit all right what I
want you to do is I want you to put both
feet together just like this and put
your hands to your side just like this
okay what I'm going to have you do is
I'm going to have you uh perform a
balance test okay I'm going to
demonstrate it to you okay before you do
it don't start it until I tell you to
start okay what you're going to do is
you're going to take either leg of your
choice keep your hands at your side
you're going to raise that leg up all
right and you're going to point your toe
to the SK and you're going to stare at
that toe okay and you're going to count
out loud 1 1,000 2 1,000 all the way to
uh 30 or until I tell you to stop okay
do you understand 1 1,000 I have to say
1,000 after every time okay 1 1,000 2
1,000 3 1,000 do you understand though
yes or you want me demonstrate lifting
my leg yep okay all right whenever
you're ready okay 1 1,00 2 1,00 3 1,000
4 1,000 5 1,000 6 1,000 7 1 1 8 1,00 9
1,00 10 1,00 11 1,00 12 1,00 13
1,45 all right you can stop all right so
what we to do is we want you to stand on
this line here okay and turn around and
face me turn around face me all right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
demonstrate this test for you okay and
what I want you to do is just watch me
do it all right but before we start the
test or or I start demonstrating it I
want you to take your right foot put it
in front of your left foot just like
this go ahead and do that now all right
and just hold that position all right
what you're going to do is you're going
to walk Heel To Toe nine steps okay when
you get to that ninth step you're going
to stop and you're going to take a
series of small steps and turn around
and go back and do Heel To Toe nine
steps okay so it's going to look just
like this and you're going to keep your
hands at your side you're going to go
one 2 3 4 5 6 7 7 8 9 then when you get
to nine you're going to take just a
series of small steps and do the same
thing back you understand okay all right
whenever you're
ready
two now what do body cams like this show
you that it's an unpredictable world
right and sometimes in that world you're
going to need a lawyer but finding the
right legal help is so important and let
me take a minute then to thank attorney
Tom and Associates for sponsoring this
body cam you see whether you were
injured in a car wreck or Refinery
explosion or the victim of Securities
fraud or received a notification that
your information was included in a data
breach developed an illness as a result
of a bad drug or toxic exposure and
there are so many other situations
attorney Tom can help you see what Tom
and his team do so well is they not only
have the legal knowledge of course but
they have genuine empathy for their
clients and having someone you can trust
is invaluable and by the way every call
is free it's private you'll be speaking
with a member of his team straight away
you won't pay a dime until you win which
just shows their commitment to your
success and they have an impressive
track record in tough tough cases and
look if your case is not the best fit
for attorney Tom and his team don't
worry because they still may be able to
recommend you a lawyer because they have
a national network of attorneys they can
refer you to with attorney Tom and his
team you're not just hiring lawyer
you're getting powerful allies who are
committed to Justice and your well-being
so if you've suffered an injury and you
need legal support click the attorney
tom.com bodycam link pinned in the
comments for a free consultation or dial
855 Tom
wins 1 2
four 5
6 all right all right one more test okay
what I'm going to have you do is I'm
going to have you keep stand just like
you are hands to your side feet together
and I'm going to have you follow my
finger okay with your eyes only okay
okay don't move your head don't move
your body do you
understand keep your eyes open okay okay
[Music]
you got to keep your eyes open
okay
okay all right so based on everything
that's been going on tonight the
accident your admission okay and your
tests I do believe that you're under the
influence of alcohol right now okay no I
okay all right so what what I'm going to
have you do is I'm going to have you
turn around okay all right put your
hands behind your
okay can you please just let them know
yeah don't know thank
you all right going to go what's
that can you please just let them know
yeah I'll all right thank
you I'm so
sorry building it's going to be no it's
going to be the one on groeling cuz
that's the one she was
driving the one that yeah there's
two yeah I
know hold on I'll be right there hold
on holy
shit fuck do I get a call or something
we'll we'll explain everything
okay all right how's see just watch your
watch your head okay thank
[Music]
you
I
the uh vehicle comes back to the female
you can uh vate she's under arrest for
450 right
now to
call
yeah it's going to be for a vehicle
on yes
[Music]
okay here4 I'll be coming 101 with that
female mileage 63
032 46 or 48 do we know where the
keys where' you leave your keys
at um I don't know if my keys are still
on my apartment or inside of the car
which is still which is still be
um right where the Walgreens is yeah no
we know where your car is I just didn't
know if you left the keys in it or not
yeah I know for a fact that my home keys
are inside of the house but my car keys
might still be inside of the
[Music]
car you
have
this is so
[Music]
Weir
see here 44 don't close 70 I can't get
in far enough for uh it to close
properly all right follow
me every to wipe my face later yeah I'll
I'll get you some a tissue in a
okay do I have like the phone call or
something yeah when we're done when
we're done with everything I'll let you
make a phone call okay thank
you all right turn around
okay just spread your hands out a little
bit there you
go
there you go have a seat you don't have
your phone on you do you no okay all
[Music]
right
there you go thank you
[Music]
yep
for
so the the females the what's your first
name again
Lanna lyanna the the that blue vehicle
that I gave you that should come back
with lyanna something yeah she's she's
in is she in there
yet oh
okay okay well that that's who I have
just so you know all
[Music]
right
all
for
Lanna is how you say your name yeah okay
all right so I got to read something to
you okay so if you just uh try and pay
attention and uh and if you have any
questions wait until after I'm done
reading it okay okay all right you have
been arrested for driving driving while
intoxicated
39450 the law requires you to submit
samples of your breath for the purpose
of testing to determine alcohol content
a record of the taking of the breast
samples including the test results will
be made upon your request a copy of that
record will be made available to you
after you have provided samples of your
breath for testing you have the right at
your own expense to have a person or
physician of your own selection take
independent samples of your breath blood
or urine for independent testing if you
refuse to provide samples of your your
breath you will be issued a separate
summon for the refusal a court may find
you guilty of both refusal and driving
while
intoxicated if a court finds you guilty
of the refusal you'll be subject to
various penalties including licensed
revocation of up to 20 years a fine of
up to $2,000 installation of an ignition
interlock and a referral to an
intoxicated driver Resource Center these
penalties may be in addition to
penalties imposed by the court for any
other offense of which you're found
guilty you have no legal right to have
an attorney physici or anyone else
present for the purpose of taking the
breast samples you have no legal right
to refuse to give or delay giving
samples of your breath any response from
you that is ambiguous or conditional in
any respect my request that you provide
breast samples will be treated as a
refusal to submit the breath
testing even if you agree to take the
test but then do not follow my
instructions do not properly perform the
test or do not provide sufficient breath
samples I will charge you with refusal
to submit to breath testing I repeat the
all required you to submit samples of
your breath for testing will you submit
the samples of your breath
[Music]
yes